March is upon us time to do a little
spring cleaning in your bank account
here are eight of the biggest games
releasing in March 2023
I hope you're done with the Dead Space
remake because this month another
classic survival horror game is hopping
back into the spotlight with a Fresh
coat of paint in Resident Evil 4 you
play as Leon Kennedy in a quest to save
the president's daughter after she is
kidnapped by a dangerous cult gamespot's
very own Kurt indovina got to play the
Remake back in October of 2022 and said
quote Resident Evil 4 remake doesn't
feel like it's aiming to revolutionize
games the way it did 17 years ago
instead Capcom is doubling down on what
has made Resident Evil 4 Timeless all
these years later its design its tension
and of course Leon S Kennedy in doing so
its goal is to emphasize what remains
great while fine-tuning it with
everything the franchise has learned in
its 26 years of existence you can relive
re4 or play it for the first time when
the game release on March 24th for PS5
series xns and PC while long Fallen
dining Dynasty is an action RPG set in
China during 184 A.D just before the
fall of the Han Dynasty and the start of
the Three Kingdoms period however this
is not your average retelling of ancient
Chinese history according to team ninja
will long Fallen Dynasty is a dark
fantasy one where players must ward off
ancient demons as they fight for
survival combat and woolong will be
based on traditional martial arts and
will emphasize graceful movement and
deflection similar to sekuro's posture
system wolong's enemies have Spirit
systems that indicate their level of
agitation with attacks and perfect
parries being the quickest way to make
it rise and open your opponents up for a
fatal strike core to wolong's gameplay
is its morale system which indicates the
strength of both your character and your
opponents by defeating enemies with a
higher morale rank than your character
their own morale increases faster and
more valuable items will be dropped
while long Fallen Dynasty is slicing and
dicing its way onto the the current and
previous generation of consoles as well
as PC on March 3rd WWE 2k23 is the
follow-up to last year's successful
relaunch of the rustling game franchise
which took a year off after the
disastrous WWE 2k20 the new game
features John Cena as the cover star and
the primary focus of this year's
showcase mode with the war games match
type being added to a WWE game for the
first time in our preview for the game
we said quote outside of the learning
curve of its rules War Games is a breath
of fresh air for a franchise that needed
something special to keep up with the
television product once you embrace the
utter chaos within the confines of two
wrestling rings enclosed in a cage the
match type is one of the most fun and
Innovative things 2k games has done with
the franchise in years another new
gameplay element in 2k23 is how you kick
out of pin Falls you can use the
traditional pound the buttons until your
fingers fall off way or you can select a
new variation of this in which a bar
pops up and there's a smaller Red Bar
moving back and forth which you must
line up with your cursor and then flick
up on the right control stick WWE 2k23
is entering the ring on March 17th for
both generation of consoles as well as
PC Crime Boss is a first person shooter
with a star-studded cast that includes
Michael Madsen Danny Trejo Vanilla Ice
Chuck freaking Norris and more the
gameplay reveal trailer released in
December of 2022 focused on a co-op
heist mission and showed off the game
stealth shotguns and ARS as well as the
members of the crew being knocked down
and revived publisher 505 games and
developer in-game Studios say Crime Boss
Rocket City will feature a roguelike
campaign Sheriff Norris played of course
by Chuck Norris will be attempting to
stop players along with gang overlords
like vanilla ice pull off the perfect
Heist on current gen consoles and PC via
game store on March 28th aside from the
game's two cover Stars Jazz Chisholm on
the standard and Derek Jeter on the
captain Edition there is not much known
about this year's game at the time I'm
writing this video's script what we do
know however is the addition of the new
game mode story lines which will follow
a single player from the Negro Leagues
using both gameplay and short video
vignettes to tell their story eight
players will make up the first season of
the Negro leaks content with more to
follow throughout the year get your
glove ready because MLB the Show 23 is
flying into the outfield on March 28th
for PlayStation 4 5 Xbox One series X
and S and switch in this dead cells and
Castlevania crossover DLC the beheaded
is recruited by Vampire Slayer Richter
Belmont to explore Dracula's castle
encountering a familiar face and a heap
of new enemies along the way some of
these new enemies include werewolves
skeletons and of course vampires players
will get to experience 4 teen new
weapons two brand new biomes to explore
and two epic new bosses where they'll
face off against classic Castlevania
antagonist death and Dracula Dracula's
castle will be waiting for you on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one switch and PC
this March 6th
Fatal Frame mask of the lunar eclipse is
finally heading to the West a survival
horror game developed by koi Tecmo in
2008 for the Nintendo Wii Fatal Frame
mask of the lunar eclipse was originally
only released in Japan lunar eclipse is
the fourth game in the Fatal Frame
Series in which you play as primary
protagonist Ruka menazaki investigating
the dark past of the island that's
inhabited by malevolent Spirits fatal
frame's combat is centered around taking
pictures of ghosts with a magical camera
enemies can take different kinds of
damage based on the film used and the
composition of the shot this version of
the game adds a photo mode how fitting
alongside the usual graphical
enhancements Fatal Frame mask of the
lunar eclipse is coming to PC and all
the consoles on March 9th EA hasn't
released a golf game on consoles since
2015. that's about to end with EA Sports
PGA Tour this month the game separates
itself from PGA Tour 2k23 and part by
offering all four majors this means EA
Sports PGA Tour is the only new golf
game to feature the Masters the PGA
Championship the US Open and the open EA
Sports PGA Tour also includes the
PLAYERS Championship which is known by
many golf fans as The Unofficial fifth
major the game will feature a road to
the Masters event at launch that allows
players to compete at the Masters to try
to win their own Green Jacket EA Sports
PGA Tour will also feature multiple
amateur level events including the US
amateur that EA Sports designed and
developed in partnership with the USGA
you can go pro and hit the links on
March 24th when the EA Sports PGA Tour
drops for current generation consoles
and PC players that pre-order will gain
access on March 21st which of these
games are you most excited for let me
know in the comments and subscribe to
Gamespot for more
[Music]
thank you